[Applause]
short films allow for new voices to be
seen in her without the constraints of
budget or permission I've seen these
films and they are beautiful and if you
haven't seen it come see it thing here
here are the nominees for Best live
action short film Brotherhood
Miriam Joubert and Maria Garcia tours on
nefta Football Club Eve Pia and Dom en
megabee the neighbors window marshal
curry
Sariah Bryan Buckley and Matloff Abe a
sister
Delphine gerar
[Music]
um
duh Oscar goes to the neighbor's Widow
[Applause]
is the first Oscar and fourth nomination
for Marshall curry
[Applause]
Wow
so grateful to all the people who made
this film with me including Maria Digia
Julia John Wolfgang Elizabeth my wife
and producing partner our kids Jane and
rivers I want to dedicate this to my mom
who grew up on a peach farm in
Chesterfield South Carolina it was the
best storyteller I ever knew she she
always had a story about some crazy
thing that happened you know with her
siblings when she was growing up or some
weird dog that she had seen or or
something that the taxi driver had told
her about is about his life that would
break your heart and I learned from
watching her that that a well-told story
is um it's a powerful thing and it can
it can change the way we see the world
and it can help us to notice other
people and and care about those other
people and and maybe love each other a
little bit more so this is for her and
for all the storytellers thank you
[Applause]